كثير من هذا يعود ببساطه لامر غير مقبول
وبالتالي دعوني اكون واضحا لن اتفق على
الصفقه تحمي
35 مليار دولار
حققت او
ادت الى هذا
التاخير في في العوائد من قطاع النفط لن
اتفق على هذا هذه الصفقه
التي
تؤثر على
الاجور للمعلمين ولا رواتب المتقاعدين
وكذلك
مختلف الوظائف في
جميع قطاعات الولايات المتحده او صفقه
تحمي الاثرياء
بينما الدافع الدافع الضريبه سيتاثر
ولا يوجد اي اتفاق
بين الحزبين على مثل هذه الشروط لابد من
زحزحه هذه الشروط والجميع اتفق معي على ان
الخطا ليس خيارا
نرجو ان نفي بهذا الالتزام
ولايه المتحده لم تتاخر عن ديولها ولن
تفعل
و يتحدثون لاحقا عن خطتنا في هذا الصدد
لكن
الفرق ستواصل عملها اما الان
[موسيقى]
كان خذنا بايام
مدخمه بالعمل خلال وجودنا هنا في هيروشيما
والتقينا هنا في روسيما وليس استراليا
لنتحدث مع
رئيس الوزراء الياباني والرئيس الاوكراني
ورئيس الوزراء نيوزلندي والوزراء الهندب
هذه
رحله
الرابعه للمنطقه وسيتوقف في باب جيني
واستر استراليا لاحقا
والوزير كلينك كلينكن سيصل هناك قبلي
وساستضيف وتحدثت
حول هذا الامر سيلتقي بهم في واشنطن هذا
الخريف
وكذلك سيكون لدينا ريس زارت
سعيد الدوله
واشكر الرئيس كشيده على قيادته
المتميزه
لهذه المجموعه هذه
سنلتقي ايضا في
مقره
استرحاء الشهيد وكذلك
صرح المقاتلين القدامى وبالتالي هذه
المنطقه الان تشهد السلام والان نحن في
مجموعه السبعه اكدنا التزامنا لمواصله
العمل لعالم خال من تهديد السلاح النووي
خلال الايام الاخيره
ارد استعرضنا الوحده وحده وحده الهدف بين
مجموعه السبعه وهي مختلفه عما كانت عليه
قبل خمس او عشر سنوات فهي تعالج التحديات
الاخطر للعالم نحن متحدين في ج لحمايه
الامن العالمي
وخطه الولايات المتحده
لتمويل
البنك الدولي
لتمويل مواجهه
الجائحه وبالتالي لنكون قادرين على مواجهه
اي جائحه مستقبليه
والاستثمار في هذه القطعه في المستقبل نحن
متحدين في دفعنا
لاقتصاد عالمي قادر على امتصاص صدمات
العالميه الاقتصاديه
وبناء
سلاسل امداد اكثر امنا واكثر استقرارا
واستثمارات التي اطلقناها في مجموعه
السبعه في المانيا
تحدثنا عن احتياجاتنا وكثير من الدول
في الجنوب جنوب العالم فنحن قمنا بحشد
اكثر من 30 مليار دولار من المشاريع في
العالم وهي خطوه مهمه نحو التزامنا
لحجز ستمائه مليار دولار في استثمارات
بحلول 20 27 ونحن عازمين على
مراقبه بنوك التنمويه لتكون فيها اكثر
مرونه لمواجهه التحديات العالميه انا
مع جمهوريه الصين نحن
اكدنا على المبادئ الاساسيه التي اتفقنا
عليها في مجموعه السبع في تعاملنا مع
الصين لا نسعى للانفصال عن الصين بل تقليل
المخاطر وتنويع هذه العلاقه هذا يعني ان
نتخذ خطواتنا نحو تنميه
سلاسل الامداد ولا نكون دوله محتكره لمنتج
معين وبالتالي ليكون كي لا يكون هناك
وسائل لاجبار الاطراف من خلال احتكار
سيلان وجميع الاعضاء في مجموعه سبعه
اتفقوا على هذه المبادئ ونحن هنا معنا
الرئيس
ونحن اكدنا
التزامنا المشترك والاكيد
لاوكرانيا وشعبها للوقوف في وجع
عدوان الروسي
وبالتالي
ندعم
سعيهم لسلام عادل واستعاده
سيادتهم على اراضيهم وروسيا هي من بدات
هذه الحرب وروسيا عليها ان تنهيها اليوم
وسحب قواتها من الحدود المعترف بها دوليا
لاوكرانيا وحتى ذلك الحين اعتذر هنا وهذا
قدره اوكرانيا لدفاع عن نفسها وعبر
الدبلوماسيه
هذه هي طرق الخروج من هذه الاسماء ازمه
اكدنا للرئيسكي لن نتهاون
لن يكسر عزيمتنا كما كان قبل ربما ثلاث
اعوام سنسعى لتقديم المساعدات الامنيه
لاوكرانيا كيف تقف بقوه
طالما تطلب الامر ونحن
نقدم الذخيره واسلحه
الدبابات والمدرعات والمساعده اوكرانيا كي
تنجح في هذه الحرب
والتقينا
بازلن
العميل معه اننا سنبدا بالتدريب الطيارين
الاوكرانيين على
الجيل الرابع
هذا التزام طويل الامد
لتمكين اوكرانيا على القدره للدفاع عن
نفسها وان نفعل وان نتعامل مع كل ما
سيواجهونه كما يواجهونه في الوقت الراهن
وان تكون اوكرانيا قادره على الدفاع عن
نفسها
باشكال
اكثر كفاءه مما هي عليه الان
وفي الايام الاخيره
تبين
مدى اهميه القياده الامريكيه للعالم وهذه
مساله مهمه
الامن
والازدهار للشعب الامريكي
يتم عبر تعاون مع حلفائنا وشركائنا وهذا
يعزز من قوتنا من خلال عالم اكثر سلما
واكثر استقرارا وكثير من القضايا المهمه
لشعبنا وهي الطاقه النظيفه والتعامل مع
قضيه الصين واوكرانيا
والاجتماعات
التي خذناها جعلتنا اكثر وحده وعزما
للوقوف امام التحديات وكان كانت هذه قمه
مهمه وبهذا
ساتلقى بضعه اسئله وسنبدا
اذا مشاهدينا كنا نتابع معكم مؤتمر صحفي
لرئيس الامريكي جو بايدن في هيروشيما على
هامش قمه السبع وتطرق بايدن لعده ملفات
حقيقه تطرق للصين والعلاقه معها واكد على
المبادئ الاساسيه في التعامل معها وانه لا
انفصال معاصين وانما تقليل للمخاطر
والاعتماد على الصينيين وتنويع سلاسل
الامداد اما في الملف الاوكراني قال بان
هناك التزام مشترك لاوكرانيا وشعبها روسيا
من بدات الحرب عليها ان تنهيها واضاف بانه
سيكون هناك تدريب للطيارين الاوكران على
الاف 16 من الجيل الرابع وسيكون هذا
التزام طويل الامد طبعا لتمكين اوكرانيا
للدفاع عن نفسها بشكل اكثر كفاءه من اليوم
وذكر بان هناك اهميه للقياده الامريكيه
للعالم وتتبين من الاحداث القائمه بحسب
تعبير بايدن واكد الالتزام لمواصله العمل
لعالم خالي من تهديد السلاح النووي نعود
الى المؤتمر لنستمع قليلا
يعني
[موسيقى]
جزء مما كنت احجج فيه منذ البدايه هو ان
نفكر بهيكليه
الضريبه
خفض الانفاق وانا اسعى لخفض الانفاق
بثلاثه تريليون دولار
واعتقد ان علينا ان ندرس مساله عوائد
الضريبه فالفكره
التي
يردوا فيها الجمهوريين ان يستمروا في
الوضع الراهن من الاعفاءات الضريبيه التي
امتدت منذ عهد ترامب نحن قدمنا
كثير
من المعطيات من الاقتصاديين من كلا
الحزبين ونحن بحاجه لمزيد من الاشخاص
المؤهلين ليتمكنوا من دراسه عوائد الضريبه
لالاف البليوناريه بليونا
من في امريكا
بالتالي يمكن ان
نحصل على 200 الى اربعه مليار دولار من
عوائد
الضريبه
وهناك من يتعربون من الضريبه وتمكننا من
موازنه الميزانيه
وتمكنا
منخفض واحد فاصل سبعه مليار دولار من
العجز الذي تراكم
لاننا تمكنا من
تحديد 55 شركه التي حققت
40 400 مليار دولار ان
عليهم
ان يدفعوا ضريبه على الاقل 50%
الان تمكنا من موازنه الميزانيه وقللنا
العجز بواحد فاصل سبعه مليار دولار هذه
امور كثيره اذا ذلك جانب المؤتمر الصحفي
مشاهدينا للرئيس الامريكي جو بايدن في
هيروشيما تطرق كما ذكرنا على عده ملفات
منها الصين واوكرانيا والدوره الروسي طبعا
في بدايه هذه الحرب عليهم ان ينهيهم طبعا
تطرق بانهم سيتم تدريب طيارين اوكرانيا من
الجيل الرابع وهذا التزام طويل الامد تطرق
ايضا للالتزام التام للعمل لعالم خالي من
تهديد السلاح النووي وتطرق كذلك للجائحه
وبذل الجهود حول التصدي لاي جائحه
مستقبليه وعالم قادر على امتصاص الصدمات
العالميه المستقبليه لمتابعه المزيد من
الاخبار والبرامج والقصص الانسانيه
والوثائقيات والتقارير الاخباريه لا تنسوا
الاشتراك في قناتنا على يوتيوب الضغط على
زر الاعجاب وتفعيل جرس التنبيهات